Parliament's all over the world throw
their doors open to the public to give
us an idea about what they do ever
wondered what it's like the side view of
Parliament time to take a closer look
a staggering 300,000 people from across
the globe visit the Parliament every
year but remember you can just queue up
and walk in you have to book well in
advance if you want to get in on a
guided group tour to see the chamber I'm
here with an english-speaking group but
tours can be in any of the EU languages
and they can be organized for any
private or public organisation hello and
welcome to the Parliament are you ready
for your guided tour but take this
device it'll help you throughout the
guided tour in your language there you
go
but hurry up dear the lecture is about
to start pull your group over there
great thank you
time for a bit of learning once settled
in your seat an hour-long presentation
on the EU here groups learn about the
interplay between institutions and the
power structure inside Parliament a
moment also for a quick look out from
the visitors balcony from here you can
see all the hustle and bustle down below
oh my god is not that girl for new Apple
TV it's the only point at which visitors
get to see what we all do down here but
over to the main attraction the plenary
chamber guys are on hand to explain what
the Parliament is and what any piece do
we get a lot of young people coming to
visit the European Parliament a lot of
people are interested in politics there
and and when they actually can see the
chamber with their own eyes people often
are amazed at the size of it the scale
of it but also the number of languages
that are used but remember the official
seat of the Parliament is in Strasbourg
so of course for the steak place there
too
and sometimes you can even catch the mep
in action at the plenary if you book at
the right time in Strasburg people to
mingle and Walker and the Parliament all
three leaves it's still access is
limited that's why in 2011 the
parliamentarian opening its doors in
Brussels
hello and welcome foreign terraeum how
many of you I'm just the one okay we'll
take this guide just go that way and
enjoy the tour in typically use dialect
caters for all 24 languages which
languages you like English no problem
okay there you go that's all done
remember to put the strap on and that's
your earpiece Thanks it's pretty
high-tech stuff indoors with lots of
interactive tools help you learn about
Europe passing presents
as the Nobel Peace Prize is also kept
here play game here they get to step
into the shoes of any piece deciding for
themselves whether the EU should let
water solidarity or it's okay to use
chip implants but also the
parliamentarian holds temporary
exhibitions like this one from a fashion
college in Madrid representing it says
harmony and integration in Europe and at
the end of your visit you can even leave
a comment
so that's pretty much a wrap for Watson
often but in the future the Parliament
is also the midst of building at the
house of European history it should be
ready for visitors by 2015 and what
stories of Europe will that tell well
that's another story